okay this morning I was browsing the
David Pakman show subreddit over 17,000
of our viewers and listeners are now
subscribed to the David Pakman show
subreddit find it free at david
pakman.com slash read it one of the
largest progressive independent media
subreddits out there a couple of
interesting conversations and posts that
i found one from portland hipster 69 who
says fox is still doing infomercials
during impeachment they are literally
selling pillows from australia during
impeachment yeah so last week when it
was the house impeachment managers
presenting their case Fox News ran video
of the impeachment proceedings but very
often the sound would be muted and you
would either have bomb-throwing
ideologues saying things over the
impeachment hearings or sometimes they
would go to commercials like my pillow I
later found out that the my pillow guy
the owner of the my pillow company I
guess is a huge Trump supporter I had no
idea sorry as I hid my microphone and
reports are that Fox is continuing to do
this to some degree although they seem
to air a lot more of the Trump lawyers
presentations with audio than they did
the house managers not a huge surprise a
nostalgic sian says has anyone noticed a
large amount of Mike Bloomberg ads I
swear to god 75% of my YouTube videos
have a Bloomberg ad this is seriously so
annoying if I had a dollar for every
time I heard Mike we'll get it done I
could lobby Congress for legalizing weed
yes and what we are seeing is that the
Mike Bloomberg ads are running
wall-to-wall on YouTube particularly if
you live in a a Super Tuesday State
Super Tuesday states are the states that
vote on March 3rd Massachusetts is a
Super Tuesday State I'm getting Mike
Bloomberg ads not even on political
content I'll watch like you know a
Japanese Omaha se video from someone
visiting Tokyo and it'll still run an ad
for Michael Bloomberg or I will watch
Grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura's online
YouTube videos and I will still get an
ad for Michael Bloomberg so he is
pouring cash into Super Tuesday states
and other states expected to continue
in fact this is the strategy I said on
Monday if I were Michael Bloomberg this
is exactly what I would be doing so yes
I are telling me all I get on YouTube
now are Michael Bloomberg ads we're just
gonna have to live with it for a while
anyway join the discussion on the
subreddit at david pakman.com slash
reddit do you feel like you just don't
have enough time to become as
intellectually well-rounded as you would
like to be that they're just not enough
hours in your week for you to read all
of the books that you want to read one
of our sponsors is called blinka stand
it's an app that lets you consume an
entire non-fiction book in 15 minutes
it's only about eight bucks a month but
you can try it for free for a week and
get 25% off a subscription
when you go to blankest comm slash
Pakman what blinka studs is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and condense them into either text or
audio that you can read or listen to in
just 15 minutes and what you get is all
of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen to an entire nonfiction
book in the amount of time it takes you
to drive or walk home from work I just
finished listening to the way we eat now
by bee Wilson whose work I've
recommended to you before super
interesting look at how the global food
system works and impacts the way that we
live blink is has totally transformed
how I consume information I love it of
course I read a book in its entirety
when I can but there are simply just so
many books that I want to read and would
not have the time for if it weren't for
blink Asst they have books on politics
economics philosophy science you name it
you can try it out yourself totally free
for a week and get 25% off if you decide
to subscribe just by going to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video like the
rest of us I bet you're going into 20/20
thinking about what you didn't get
around to in 2019 and your goals for the
new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you